at long last after almost two years we
made it to the final season analysis of
game of thrones season three i probably
shouldn't have skipped over seasons two
and three initially upon doing this
series but hey here we are as usual
though for this season the writing
directing acting in every form of
production is great and i'll mainly be
focusing on some unique aspects as to
what makes season 3 amazing
for most of the show there's always a
background conflict of politically
charged betrayals and to a lot of people
this is always a major highlight of the
show because it allows wardrobe martin's
writing to flourish however for the
first time in season 3 the primary
driving conflict is politically
motivated as an example season 1 is a
murder mystery season 2 is a battle
underdog conflict and season 4 is
another murder mystery season 3 is all
about the political dance and trying to
grab as much power as possible in king's
landing it's primarily the lannisters
versus the tyrells and the conflict
between them is so fresh and unique
because it isn't violent in any way
this is perfectly exemplified in taiwan
and elena's showdown of determining the
future of their houses it at first comes
across as a normal dialogue scene where
they're talking about pairing their kids
grandkids together but the second an air
of doubt arises they start to maneuver
around each other bringing up different
pieces of dirt and to combat this these
characters don't specialize in physical
violence and instead tywin intelligently
threatens to assign laura tyrell to the
kingsguard in an attempt to force alone
into tywin's terms shall i door up the
order
or do you consent to this match
it's a rare enough thing
a man who lives up to his
reputation to me clever solutions
figured out by smart characters is
extremely entertaining and can make the
writing feel like it's teeming with wit
also not only is this type of conflict
within king's landing it's also infected
the entirety of the battle of the five
kings season two is a lot more action
oriented but season three takes a step
back and allows the ward to be fought in
a different manner this is true for both
robb stark and stannis baratheon and
acts as a great change of pace for
seasons one and two we see stannis at
one of his lowest points reeling from
the loss of king's landing trying to
desperately find purpose within the lord
of lights this offers a great
juxtaposition for the character davos
who acts as more of the angel on sanus's
shoulder in comparison to melisandre and
to perfectly build to a great climax
george r martin sets up a test in which
stannis has to make the decision to
sacrifice gendry to gain an advantage in
the war so all at once with this
brilliant writing we get crazily
intriguing conflict characters having to
make groundbreaking decisions and
actions that affect the kingdom as a
whole what is the life of one bastard
boy against a kingdom
then for rob stark the action starts to
slow down since tywin is trying to not
engage with rob on the field so this
allows there to be some new conflict
namely the two biggest things being the
discord among his officers and his
relationship with the phrase this also
ties into the political intrigue spike
because his relationship with other
northern houses is integral for his
victory against the lannisters and if he
can't manage that then he'll lose the
war so oddly enough the stakes are just
as high dealing with his own allies than
they are against his enemy similar to
what is happening in king's landing
between the lannisters and the tyrells
and it's interesting because the major
downfall of rob stark isn't his strength
and military mind but his lack of
political understanding making blunder
after blunder in which he executes
rickard stark thus alienating the car
starks which are a big part of his army
and him trusting the slimy phrase after
he broke his vow it is sad to witness
this but no character can constantly go
on within the story without making
mistakes especially since actions have
consequences and my rock following his
heart and marrying to lissa he doomed
himself
so even though the conflict isn't as
drastic as season 2 season 3 is still
able to create engaging conflict without
any form of reliance on action
a big reason why season 2 may feel like
one of the weaker seasons of the first
four is that jon and daenerys didn't
have that great of a story however now
that they have found their footing more
as characters links to season two they
are able to have much more fun and
progress in a more satisfying manner and
by this i mean you probably weren't that
engaged by danny being stuck in qarth
and not really being able to get closer
to her overall goal of building an army
and getting to westeros season 3
perfectly satisfies this and george
achieves this in such a spectacular
fashion that the payoff feels orgasmic
danny getting the unsullied is easily
one of the best scenes because of the
sheer payoff for three seasons of
everyone waiting for dany to pop off on
someone and accumulate more power and
this isn't just good because it's
satisfying payoff but it's also written
expertly in which freeing the slaves
ties into daenerys overall goal of
liberating and freeing everyone held
under tyranny so there's subtext under
this twist and it's also great how the
audience wasn't aware of dany's plan to
make this development even more
surprising
through the course of season 3 for dany
there's also a major injection of more
characters which was much needed because
the only dynamic we really had before
this was with sir jorah and his dynamic
with dany is great it's just that you
need to offer up more characters so that
you can have a larger variety of
interactions like we end up getting sir
barris and selmy missandei greyworm and
daario to spruce things up sir barristan
offers a great perspective given that he
served danny's father and any
interaction he has with her is
insightful on top of it also being
wholesome missandei offers a much-needed
casual avenue that dany can utilize
since every interaction she has is
normally tied to her conquest grey worm
may seem like the most dull out of these
characters but he can still be pretty
cute considering that his surrounding
characters tend to dismantle his more
professional demeanor then lastly we
have daario who acts as a love interest
and he doesn't just add that but that
introduces a conflict and what sergiora
also loves dany despite him not being
able to pursue that so dario's presence
is like constant terminal for portal sir
jorah all of these characters makes the
dialogue encounter surrounding dany much
more complex and varied and it's
something i think most people may
overlook
then we don't just have a major
improvement for daenerys but we also
have jon snow getting a major upgrade in
the last season analysis i argued that
his journey beyond the wall felt
lackluster because he didn't have much
to do and now that season three
submerged within the free folk it makes
every scene he's in utterly entrancing
because the story can go in any
direction and the stakes are really high
will jon be discovered as a spy will he
grow more sympathetic towards their
cause and will he end up falling in love
with egret or will he uphold his vows to
the night's watch these developments are
already significantly more than what
happened in season 2 where it felt like
he was idly waiting for something big to
happen then this also thoroughly changes
jon as a character as his entire outlook
on the wildlings changes i love the
opening scene with mance where at first
jon is trying to give some [ __ ]
response as to why he wants to join them
but then he digs deeper for why he
really should join them thousands of
years ago
the first men battled the white walkers
and defeated them
i want to fight for the side
the fights for the living
did i come to the right place
this singular moment establishes a great
internal conflict for jon of wanting to
help their free folk while also not
wanting to kill his brothers something
that is explored more later on once they
go over the wall it's a perfect seat
that's planted that leads to an
outstanding resolution through the
watchers on the wall and hard home
to me this is why john's season three
through five journey is by far his peak
in the show because when he's being torn
apart between his love of egret and the
duty to his brothers and makes for an
amazing conflict especially since it was
set up in season one with mr amon's
quotes love is the death of duty so when
we go from a great internal struggle
interlaced with an equally good plot to
the later seasons where he basically
just becomes a hollow drone where he
only cares about beating the night king
you can see a clear drop off and it's
also ironic that jon's internal conflict
with a free folk in the night's watch
somehow manages to greatly surpass his
targaryen identity crisis in season
eight thanks to goodall david and dan
i think in season three the crazy
lannister family dynamic was at its best
just barely beating out season four
because tyrion was kind of locked away
for the whole season now we are
technically missing jaime in season 3
for the king's landing story but i think
the dynamic between tyrion cersei and
tywin is practically perfect and is
present throughout the entirety of the
season and it's not like jaime isn't
being well utilized this season given
that he has his all-time best scene with
brienne where he spells the truth about
the mad king but going back to king's
landing the beauty of it is that it's a
capital which so many characters
intertwine and have a chance to interact
with each other am i bringing in a
collection of rich and complex
characters that have layers of
backgrounds with each other is going to
lead to outstanding dialogue scenes
influence grows like a weed
any man who must say i am the king is no
true king
chaos is a ladder
in the first episode alone we have one
of tyrion and tywin's best scenes
together in which tywin is being
truthful about how he feels about tyrion
it's utterly tragic and the once
confident tyrion is reduced to a scared
child as his father castrates him
verbally you are an ill-made spiteful
little creature
full of envy lust and low cunning but
neither gods nor men will ever compel me
to let you turn casterly rock into your
[ __ ] house and this is all after turn
is just looking for some praise from his
heroic acts in the battle of the black
water
to me taiwan and tyrion is the best
rivalry in the show because of the pure
conflict between them a father that
fundamentally hates his child while that
child desperately craves his approval
and instead constantly gets beaten down
by him and it also makes it even better
that these are the two best characters
in the show and talon in particular is
the most powerful man alive so having an
intimate relationship with this figure
is infinitely intriguing i'm kind of
gushing about tyrion and tywin right now
and there's also you know another
magnificent character that's included in
this dynamic which is cersei a character
who was once dominant in king's landing
for the first two seasons is put in
check by her father is definitely an
interesting change of pace for her
especially during the explosive scene
where tywin's so fed up with his
children and not wanting to comply with
the tyrells that he screams at them and
asserts his chad dominance you're my
daughter
you will do as i command and you will
marry loras tyrell
this also brings up a point of relation
since tyrion and cersei are both
subjected to their father so they stop
fighting each other and grow a bit
closer their scenes together this season
are so moving especially since tyrion
can even relate to the fact that now
he's starting a quote-unquote family
with sansa so he can kind of relate to
cersei's family drama this unlocks that
rare dialogue where cersei opens up
about her kids and becomes more warm and
intimate with tyrion and i find these
types of moments extremely juicy
how happy would you say you are
not very
but if it weren't for my children
i'd have thrown myself from the highest
window in the red keep
so although for season three there isn't
a major plot driven device like an
upcoming war or a sprawling murder
mystery to inherently up the excitement
factor i think the season is still able
to compete with the others because of
how it's still able to be extremely
engaging with its complex characters
hashing out intimate issues
after season one of game of thrones you
think wow george r martin just played
the biggest uno reverse card in cinema
history by killing the main protagonist
and there is no way it'll happen again
oh no no no pepe left we were so naive
going into season three the red wedding
is definitely the best scene in the show
and i've talked about it a lot so have
other people however i can't make a
season three analysis without going into
it now to throw the obvious things out
first the technical makeup of the scene
is perfect from the acting the writing
delivery pace tone everything about the
scene is executed at such an amazing
degree for me the personal standout is
michelle farrelly's performance as
catelyn and her extreme reaction to the
death of her son exudes a haunting layer
of dread and shock that traumatizes
everyone in the audience thanks to
george r martin making such an expansive
and sprawling story with dozens of major
characters he can do something like this
and not completely damage the story
beyond repair you look at any other show
and the cast of characters is normally
just a handful and because of that fact
you can't do anything major with them
without ruining the story this is why
game of thrones is special with such a
huge cast georgia martin can play with
the set foundations of storytelling and
make it seem like certain characters are
going to be the main character only to
swipe out the rug this makes every
character have an are of danger and
suspense around them because we don't
know how safe they are and whether the
story will continue for them this is why
i think the later seasons of the show
really fall off not to mention the
writing because once you get a set
number of main characters that you know
will make it to the end you can slowly
start to see their plot armor and any
danger around them evaporates making the
show have less tension the red wedding
is a major reminder of danger and
doesn't just impact one storyline but
makes the viewer worry about everyone so
not only is the scene in achievement and
storytelling it causes a massive ripple
effect and how you view the show as a
whole making it a complete masterpiece
so yeah those four unique reasons are
why i think season 3 stands out and is
amazing thank you guys so much for
watching through this series and if you
haven't seen my other season analysis
videos then you can check them out in
the end screen playlist and since it's
also been two years since i started this
series i feel like i drastically changed
so it may be a bit drawing going back to
some of my earlier video essays but
regardless have a great day